Guten Abend, mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und
ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja Doktor, natürlich. Okay, bitte fragen Sie nicht,
fragen Sie bitte, wenn Sie nicht etwas verstehen, okay? Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Alfred Huber. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam
buchstabieren? H-L-F-R-E-D.
Alfred H-U-B-E-R. Huber. Okay, Herr Huber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
2. April 1956. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 Meter. Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
83. Okay, danke für die Informationen. Herr Huber, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit? Ich habe Lymphknotenschwellungen Doktor.
Wo genau diese Beschwerden, Herr Huber? In welchem Körper teile ich meine?
Ja, dieser Problem ist an meinem Hals. Nur einseitig oder beiseitig?
Beiseitig. Seit wann leiden Sie unter dieses Problem?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich dieses Problem, Doktor.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie unter geschwollenen Lymphknoten leiden.
Ja. Nach wie vielen Fragen? Sind diese geschwollenen Lymphknoten schmerzhaft oder
schmerzlos? Schmerzlos. Ich habe keinen Schmerzbemerk, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Huber, haben Sie ähnliche Probleme in einem anderen Körperteil bemerkt?
Ich meine Leistungbereich, Achselhöhe? Andere Lymphknotenschwellungen, Achsel oder
Leisten gegen. Aber ich nicht bemerk, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Schluckstörungen? Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Aber außerdem fühle ich mich gratis, Doktor. Ich bin total müde.
Okay. Ich verstehe. Herr Huber, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich keinen Appetit, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirkürlich abgenommen?
Ja, in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich etwa 10 Kilogramm abgenommen, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe. Herr Huber, haben Sie eine Hautfarbeveränderung oder
Hautveränderung bemerkt, wie zum Beispiel feuchte Haut, Haarausfall,
durch den Nägel? Ja. Ja, nein, Doktor. Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Herzstorpen?
Nein, Doktor. Okay. Herr Huber, fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich erinnere mich jetzt. Seit etwa einer Woche
habe ich auch Fieber, ja. Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich fieberig, ja Doktor.
Leiden Sie unter Schüterfrost? Nein, aber ich habe starke
Schwiezen in der Nacht, ja. Okay. Alles klar.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keine dieser Probleme, nein. Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim
Wasserlässt oder mit dem Stuhlgang? Ich habe seit langem
seit langem seit, ja, habe ich Verstopfung.
Okay. Seit langem haben Sie Verstopfung und nehmen Sie dagegen
ein Medikament ein? Ja, ich nehme Movicol bei Bedarf ein, ja.
Okay. Alles klar. Schlafen Sie gut? Nein. Ich leide aber schon lange
unter Schlafstörungen, Doktor. Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen
oder durchzuschlafen? Einschlafen, ja. Einschlafen Probleme habe ich, ja.
Seit langem haben Sie gesagt? Ja, seit langem, seit langem, ja.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament oder ein
plastischer Mittel ein? Ja, ich habe beim EDK
eine Schlafmittel gekauft, aber jetzt erinnere ich mich, wie heißt Doktor.
Okay. Herr Kuba, leiden Sie unter Hürsten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe keine dieser Probleme, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und
Corona-Infektionen geimpft? Ja, ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft,
sowie viermal gegen Covid-19, ja. Okay. Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck,
Krankheit? Ja, ich leide an Blut, Hyperlipidemie, ja.
Hyperlipidemie. Seit zehn Jahren, Doktor.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein? Ich nehme Zimvostatin 40
Milligramm abends ein. Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Ich habe auch einen Bandscheibenvorfall in der Lendenfibersaule
seit über zehn Jahren, ja. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich nehme bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 6 Milligramm, bei Bedarf ein Doktor.
600 Milligramm, ja? 600 Milligramm, ja.
Okay. Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Ja, auch habe ich eine chronische
Konjunktivität seit drei Jahren, ja. Und eine linke
Ezeitege, Pielonephritis, die Ambulant behandelt wurde.
Wann war das, Herr Huber? Vor zwei Jahren.
Der Doktor hat mir eine Antibiotik gegeben, aber ich erinnere mich
nicht jetzt, Doktor. Okay. Herr Huber, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt
oder Ihre Hausärztin? Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmidt.
Okay. Ich werde Ihr Hausarzt kontaktieren, okay?
Okay, okay, danke schön. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Okay. Sie haben eine chronische Binderhautentzündung seit drei
Jahren. Benutzen Sie dagegen etwas? Ja, ich nehme eine
Eugentropfen, aber ich erinnere mich nicht jetzt, wie heißt
Doktor. Okay. Benutzen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Bei Bedarf, bei Bedarf. Alles klar. Sind Sie schon einmal
operiert worden? Ich habe nicht operiert.
Ja, Doktor. Ich erinnere mich nicht jetzt, Doktor.
Vor zwei Tagen wurde ich für zwei Tage stationär aufgenommen
wegen einer Gehirneschütterung nach dem Einfall.
Okay, alles klar. Was für ein Unfall ist das?
Darf ich fragen? Autounfall? Fahrradunfall?
Okay. Okay. Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Unfall.
Ein Unfall? Fahrradunfall?
Okay. Okay.
Außerdem wurde einmal ambulant ein Trunkel am Rücken operiert.
Okay. Herr Huber, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf
außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen
Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergen bekannt?
Ich habe eine bekannte R.B. Allergie.
R.B. Allergie, ja.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Wenn ich Erdbeeren esse, sprühe ich ein Krippen im Mund
und ein Taibheizgefühl auf der Zunge, ja.
Okay. Herr Huber, raufen Sie?
Ja, leider. Ich habe früher geraut etwa 20 Jahre lang.
Entschuldigung, 40 Jahre lang.
Wie viel haben Sie geraucht?
Täglich 10 Zigaretten, ja.
Aber momentan raufen Sie nicht, oder?
Ja, ungefähr 10 Jahre habe ich damit aufgehört, ja.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Es war schwer, aber ich habe bestanden, Doktor, ja.
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich nur als Dertel.
Vielleicht ein bis zwei Gläser Bier am Wochenende, ja.
Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Herr Huber, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen
von den, ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Brüthochtdruck?
Ja, mein Vater ist 73 Jahre alt, an Kerlkrebs gestorben, ja.
Mein Beileid, Herr Huber. Und Ihre Mutter?
Zu meiner Mutter habe ich keinen Kontakt, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, meine Schwester lebt ebenfalls im Altenheim.
Sie hatte vor vier Jahren einen hemologischen Schlaganfall, ja.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin allein stand und lebe im Altenheim, Doktor.
Habe ich drei gesunde Söhne.
Okay, Sie sind ja jetzt recht alt.
Sie sind ja jetzt Rentner, ich glaube, ja, Herr Huber.
Ja, ich bin Rentner, ja.
Was haben Sie früher als beruflich gemacht?
Ich habe früher bei einer Baufirma gearbeitet, Doktor.
Okay, Herr Huber, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich?
Ich habe gesagt, mein Vater hat an Kerkops Krebs gestorben.
Und ich habe viele Angst.
Habe ich Krebs?
Herr Huber, ich möchte Sie beruhigen, weil der Krebs nicht hundertprozentig vererblich ist.
Ja, also ohne weitere Untersuchungen kann ich leider keine Diagnose,
sicher Diagnose bezüglich des Krebses abgeben.
Zuerst müssen wir Sie körperlich untersuchen und dann müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald die alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Wurde bei mir eine Operation durchgeführt, Doktor, oder?
Aufgrund Ihren aktuellen Anamnesen denke ich, dass Sie keine Operation brauchen, Herr Huber.
Aber wie gesagt, ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit Lymphknoten haben.
Wenn Sie sagen, das kann eine Infektion sein oder andere Probleme, müssen wir zuerst die Diagnose bestätigen.
Dann können wir über die Therapiemöglichkeiten und die Diagnose 100% widersprechen.
Könnte es sein, ob ich im Krankenhaus bleibe oder kann ich in mein Altenheim gehen?
Herr Huber, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Ich werde auch.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Herr Alfred Huber ist 69 Jahre alt, 1,75 Meter groß und 83 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Huber stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Wochen bestehender indolenter beiseitiger cervicaler Lymphadenopathie vor.
Den Patienten zufolge leidet er unter chronischer Fatigue und sowie Inapetenz.
Außerdem klagte er der Patient über Gewichtsabnahme von 10 Kilogramm innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Er berichtete über Pyrexie und nächtliche Hyperhydrose, aber der Patient habe das Fieber nicht gemessen.
Die Fragen nach feuchter Haut, alle Pz, Nagelveränderungen, Tachikade wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Seit Langem bestehende Obstipation.
Der Patient nehme dagegen Movicol, Tabletten bei Bedarf ein und Insomni in Form von Einschlafstörungen.
Der Patient nehme dagegen ein Schlafmittel ein.
Der Name von Medikamenten sollte geklärt werden.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und viermal gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 10 Jahren bestehende Hyperlipidemie, seit 10 Jahren bestehende Discus prolaps im Lendenbereich,
seit drei Jahren bestehende chronische Konjunktivitis und vor zwei Jahren diagnostizierte linkseitige Pyronephritis,
die mit Antibiotika behandelt worden sei.
Der Patient nehme Zymgmastatin 40 mg abends und Ibuprofen 600 mg bei Bedarf ein und er benutze Augentropfen gegen chronische Konjunktivitis bei Bedarf.
Vor zwei Tagen erlitt der Patient eine Komodio cerebre nach einem Fahrradunfall,
die stationär behandelt worden sei und er sei gegen eine Fronkühe am Rücken operiert worden.
Der Patient habe Erdbeereallergien, die sich durch Parasthesie im Mund und Hypostesie auf der Zunge äußert.
Er sei Ex-Raucher und davor habe er 10 Sekunden täglich 40 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinke ein bis zwei Gläser Bier am Wochenende und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 73 Jahren an Larynx-Karzinom verstorben sei
und der Patient habe keinen Kontakt mit der Mutter.
Er habe eine Schwester und seine Schwester lebe in einem Altenheim.
Vor vier Jahren habe sie ein hemorrhagisches Apoplex erlitten.
Der Patient lebe alleine in einem Altenheim und habe gesunde drei Söhne.
Er sei Rentner, früher habe er in einer Baufirma gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Mobus-Hotschkin aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter schmerzlose, bilaterale, cervicale Lymphadenopathie, Gewichtsabnahme von 10 kg innerhalb von 3 Monate und nächtliche Hyperhydrose und Pyrexie.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Mobus-Hotschkin.
Die PzF-Diagnosen kommen mit Abstand-Bavirus-Infektion, Thyroid-Karzinom, Hyperthyriose in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei den Patienten zunächst die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob geschwollene Lymphknoten im Achselhöhle, im Leistenbereich, Herpatomegalie, Splenomegalie, Hautfarbeveränderungen vorhanden sind.
Ich würde die Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten und Tumor Marcus bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgenwestorax durchführen, um die möglichen mediastinalen Lymphknoten zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Thyroid-Tomographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Fein-Nadelbiopsie durchführen, um meine Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Ich würde auch eine PET-Computer-Tomographie durchführen, um die mögliche Metastase zu beurteilen.
Und ich würde auch eine Abdominalsomographie durchführen, um eine Herpatomegalie oder Splenomegalie zu beurteilen.
Sollte sich die Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und würde ich ein Onkologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Ich würde eine Chemotherapie und Radiotherapie für die Therapie des Patienten empfehlen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Wie können wir die hochkindleform genau beurteilen oder diagnostizieren?
Wir sollen eine Fein-Nadelbiopsie durchführen, um eine histopathologische Untersuchung zu machen.
Bei der histologischen Untersuchung können wir Rheid-Sternberg-Zellen feststellen.
Würden wir in diesem Fall eine Abdominalsomographie durchführen?
Abdominalsomographie ist sinnvoll für diese Patienten, um eine Leber- oder Milz-Patologie zu beurteilen.
Wir sollen auf jeden Fall eine Abdominalsomographie durchführen.
Würden wir eine Knochenmarkbiopsie durchführen?
Würden wir eine Petz-CT durchführen?
Können Sie uns eine Petz-CT aufklären?
Die Abdominalsomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Wir sollen vor der Untersuchung eine geringe Menge radioaktiver Stoffe verbreiten.
Wir sollen etwa eine Stunde warten, bis die radioaktiven Stoffe in den Körper genau verteilen.
Danach sollen wir eine Computer-Tomographie durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten ruhig in einer CT-Röhre liegen.
Wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir ihm ein Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung.
Es gibt einige Kontraindikationen, wie zum Beispiel Schmangenschaft und Kontrastmittelallergie.
Vor der Untersuchung soll der Patient sechs Stunden nicht mehr essen, aber der Patient darf viel trinken.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient auch viel trinken, um die radioaktiven Stoffe schnell auszuscheiden.
Wie können wir extra-Virus-Infektionen ausschließen?
Wir können einen Schnelltest durchführen, um die Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Wir können auch die Serologiewerte überprüfen, wie Kapsizantigen oder Nükleantigenwerte.
Die klinischen Befunde können wir uns helfen, um die Diagnose zu bestätigen, wie zum Beispiel
Exanthem oder schwelende, schmerzhafte, militärale, cervicale Lymphadenopathie, manchmal geschwollene Mandeln und chronische Müdigkeit.
Die Beschwerden sind ähnlich, aber bei Möbus-Hotschgen gibt es schmerzlose Lymphadenopathie,
bei der Epstein-Bavus gibt es eine schmerzhafte Lymphadenopathie.
Wie können wir die Hypothyroidose ausschließen?
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir eine Thyroid-Ultrasonographie durchführen.
Wenn es Knoten oder einige Befunde für eine Hypothyroidose gibt, können wir eine Thyroid-Ultrasonographie durchführen,
um die kalte und heiße Knoten zu beurteilen.
Anschließend können wir eine Feinnahtbiopsie.
Wie können wir die Hypothyroidose ausüben?
Würden Sie die Labyrinthe mit einer Hypothyroidose ausüben?
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir die Funktion Werte von der Thyroidose kontrollieren,
wie z.B. TSH, T3, T4, TPO, Antikörper, TG, T-R, TG.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten während der Behandlung und nach der Behandlung?
Ich empfehle, die Patienten mit dem Arzt zu besuchen.
Ich empfehle, ihm vorsichtig zu sein, besonders gegen Infektionen.
Das ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten.
Regelmäßige Lebensstile, regelmäßige Bewegung sind sehr wichtig für das Immunsystem.
Er lebt in einem Altenheim.
Ein Altenheim ist ein Risikofaktor für die Infektionen.
Deswegen muss der Patient vorsichtig sein gegen die Infektionen.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten Physiotherapie und ausreichende Ernährung?
Ja, genau.
Ausreichende Ernährung ist auch wichtig bei den Patienten für ein starkes Immunsystem
und auch eine Physiotherapie können wir auf jeden Fall durchführen.
Würden Sie während der Behandlung kontrollierte PZT durchführen?
Ja, Chemotherapie und Strahlentherapie werden für mehrere Male dauern.
Nach der Behandlung sollen wir auf jeden Fall eine PZT durchführen, um die Therapieantwort zu beurteilen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberz.
Sie haben eine sehr flüssige Antwort.
Gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihre Arbeit.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberz.
Ich wünsche Ihnen ein angenehmes Sprechen bei mir.
Vielen Dank.